the think-pair-share strategy is one of
the classic active learning strategies
that that one can use in one's classes
and it has as you might guess three
parts to think the pair and the share
often there's a collapsing of the pair
and the share but but in general you
first give students time to think about
a question or a situation or some other
scenario that you want them to think
about and you give them time to think
actively but alone about that and often
you can ask them to write down their
thoughts but then at the end of that
short period of time whether it's three
minutes or five minutes you have them
pair up and if it's a really big class
or the numbers the numbers of students
in your class warrant it you can have
them triple up it doesn't have to be a
pair and they discuss whatever it is
they came up with it's just a
opportunity for them to just say here
this is what I thought of what did you
think about it what did you think about
what I said so it's just an interactive
opportunity for the students to hear
from their peers and then the the key
part when they're talking to each other
is that the instructor should walk
around the room and kind of eavesdrop on
what the students are saying so you want
to understand the kinds of things
they're talking about maybe not the
specific details but the kinds of things
they're talking about and pretty quickly
you can learn if students are on the
right track or if there's a big
misconception that maybe they're just
they might be reinforcing each other's
misconceptions so you want to know that
as the instructor so that's why if
possible to walk around the room and
just overhear what people are saying
that can be a really important part of
that pair step and then for the share
you have them report out so this does
two things one it lets you bring to
light any specific comments that you
overheard during the pair section you
can bring it up with the full with the
whole class because there could be some
really important wonderful observations
the students make within the pair and if
you don't share that or if you don't
create a situation where that can be
shared with the bigger class then then
everybody misses out except for those
three people so it gives you an
opportunity
to do that it also gives you an
opportunity to globally clear up any
misconceptions that that you've heard
that it bubbled up from this from this
pair exercise the other thing it does is
if there's a group of two or three or
even four but I three is probably
optimal it the group reports as a group
it doesn't report as an individual so if
a student is a little insecure or may
not really want to share what he or she
thinks at a personal level or at an
individual level being able to share out
as a group is it is a bit safer is a bit
more comfortable for many students so
that's what the share part does and then
it just gets the whole the whole group
together and it lets lets you kind of
sum up the smaller conversations with
the larger group